Google AI Studio plus Gemini 3.1
Flashlight. Build and automate anything.
Google just dropped something wild. It's
called Gemini 3.1 Flashlight. And when
you pair it with Google AI Studio, you
can build AI tools, apps, and automation
systems with just a few prompts. No
code, no tech degree. And it's so fast,
it makes every other model look like
it's running in slow motion. Let me show
you exactly how this works. So, right
now, Google is rolling out one of the
most exciting AI updates we've seen this
year. And most people have no idea it
even exists. Which means if you're
watching this, you're already ahead
because what I'm about to walk you
through is going to change how you think
about building with AI. And I'm not just
saying that to sound dramatic. I
genuinely think this is one of the
biggest shifts we've seen in a long
time. So stick with me because by the
end of this video, you're going to know
exactly how to use this thing to
automate almost anything in your
business or your projects. Let me break
down what Gemini 3.1 Flashlight actually
is. Because the name sounds fancy, but
the idea is simple. Google has this
family of AI models called Gemini 3.
Think of it like a lineup. You've got
the big, heavy models that are great at
deep thinking and complex stuff. And
then you've got Flashlight. Flashlight
is the speed demon. It was built from
the ground up to be insanely fast and to
handle a massive amount of work at the
same time. We're talking about
processing thousands of requests without
breaking a sweat. And it does all of
this while still being really smart.
Now, here's where it gets interesting.
One of the coolest features they added
is something called adjustable thinking
levels. Stay with me on this because
it's a gamecher. Basically, you can tell
the AI how hard to think about
something. Now, if you need a quick
answer, you set the thinking level to
low and it fires back in a split second.
If you need it to really dig deep and
analyze something complex, you crank it
up. This means you're always getting
exactly the right balance of speed and
brain power for whatever you're working
on. No other model lets you do this the
same way. Hey, if we haven't met
already, I'm the digital avatar of
Julian Goldie, CEO of Goldie Agency.
Whilst he's helping clients get more
leads and customers, I'm here to help
you get the latest AI updates. Julian
Goldie reads every comment, so make sure
you comment below and let us know what
you think about this Gemini update. All
right, so let's talk about why this
matters for you. Because cool tech is
great, but what can you actually do with
it? And the answer is honestly kind of
insane. When you combine Gemini 3.1
flashlight with Google AI Studio, you
basically get a playground where you can
build real AI tools just by typing
prompts. No coding, no complicated
setup. You just open Google AI Studio,
pick the flashlight model, and start
telling it what to build. Let me give
you a real example. Say you run a
business and every day you get hundreds
or even thousands of images, maybe
product photos, maybe user uploads,
maybe screenshots. Normally someone on
your team has to go through all of those
one by one and sort them. That takes
forever. With Flashlight, you can build
a system that looks at every single
image, understands what's in it, and
sorts it into the right category
automatically. Shoes go in the shoe
folder. Electronics go in the
electronics folder. Furniture goes in
the furniture folder. And it does this
in seconds, not hours. Seconds because
the model is multimodal, which means it
can understand images and text and data
all at the same time. And that's just
one use case. You can use this same
approach to build content moderation
tools, media libraries, data
visualization, dashboards, and so much
more. The building blocks are all right
there inside Google AI Studio. Now,
here's another example that I think is
going to blow your mind. Imagine you run
a retail business. Every day you need
report trends, inventory updates,
marketing performance. Normally you'd
have someone pulling data from five
different places, copying it into a
spreadsheet, making charts, and then
sending it to you. That whole process
might take half a day. With Flashlight,
you can build an AI agent that does all
of that automatically. It pulls the
data, it analyzes the trends, it
generates a report, it builds a
dashboard, and it delivers it to you all
without a single person lifting a
finger. That's the power of what we're
talking about here. Now, if you want to
take everything I'm showing you today
and actually implement it in your
business step by step, you need to check
out the AI profit boardroom. It's the
best place to learn how to automate your
business with AI tools like Google
Gemini and Google AI Studio. You'll get
SOPs, walkthroughs, and a community of
people who are already doing this stuff
every single day. I'll drop the link in
the comments and description. Seriously,
go check it out because this is exactly
the kind of thing we break down in
there. All right, let's keep going
because I want to make sure you
understand just how powerful this model
is. There are four things that make
Flashlight stand out from everything
else right now. Number one is multimodal
intelligence. This model doesn't just
read text. It can analyze images. It can
process video. It can work with
structured data like spreadsheets and
databases all in one single workflow.
That means you can build tools that
combine all of these things together,
which is something that used to require
a whole team of engineers to pull off.
Number two is the adjustable thinking
levels I mentioned earlier. This is huge
quick task, low thinking, complex
analysis, high thinking, you're always
in control. Number three is speed. This
model was designed from scratch for low
latency. That's a fancy way of saying it
responds really, really fast. Benchmarks
are showing it produces answers about
two and a half times faster than
previous flash models. And the output
speed jumped by around 45%. So, if
you're building chat bots or real-time
dashboards or automation tools, this is
the model you want. Number four is
efficiency. Flashlight is built for high
volume. That means you can run thousands
and thousands of requests through it
without things slowing down or getting
clogged up. For anyone building AI tools
at scale, this is massive. So, what are
people actually building with this right
now? Let me give you a quick list
because I think it'll spark some ideas
for you. People are building AI
dashboards for their businesses.
Automated reporting agents that generate
insights every single day without being
asked. AI workflow assistants that
manage tasks and projects. Image
moderation tools that scan content
automatically. Translation pipelines
that convert content into dozens of
languages instantly. Business automation
bots that handle repetitive work. And
internal company co-pilots that help
teams work faster. And remember, all of
this is being built with simple prompts
inside Google AI Studio. You don't need
to be a developer. You don't need
machine learning experience. You just
need to know what you want to build and
be willing to experiment. Let me walk
you through how to try this yourself
right now. Step one, go to Google AI
Studio. Step two, create a new prompt.
Step three, select the model and look
for Gemini 3.1 Flashlight Preview. Step
four, start building. You can upload
PDFs, images, data sets, even videos,
and then just tell the AI what you want
it to do with that data. It's honestly
that simple. Like, now I want you to
think about this for a second. We're
living in a time where you can build a
full AI powered tool in minutes, not
months, not weeks, minutes. The barrier
to entry has never been lower, and the
tools have never been more powerful.
That combination is what makes this
moment so exciting. And here's the thing
that most people miss. It's not about
using AI to do one cool thing. is about
stacking these tools together to build
systems that run on autopilot. One AI
agent pulls your data, another one
analyzes it, another one generates
reports, another one sends them to your
team. You set it up once and it just
runs. That's the future of how
businesses operate. And with Gemini 3.1
Flashlight and Google AI Studio, that
future is available right now. So, let
me wrap this up with what I think you
should do next. First, go try Google AI
Studio today. Play with Flashlight,
upload some data, build something
simple, get a feel for how it works.
Because once you see what's possible,
you're not going to want to go back to
doing things the old way. Second, if
you're serious about using AI to
automate and scale your business, join
the AI profit boardroom. This is where
we go deep on exactly this kind of
stuff. You'll learn how to build
automation systems with tools like
Google Gemini and Google AI Studio, step
by step. No fluff. just real strategies
that work. The link is in the comments
and description. And if you want the
full process, SOPs, and over a 100 AI
use cases just like this one, join the
AI success lab. It's our free AI
community. Links in the comments and
description. You'll get all the video
notes from there, plus access to our
community of 38,000 members who are
crushing it with AI. Drop a comment
below and tell me what you're going to
build first with Flashlight. Julian
reads every single one. and I'll see you
in the next